good morning john i was listening to the
ezra klein show this week
and he and his guests were talking about
twitter and they said a thing that i
have said to you and you have disagreed
with me about
that twitter is both indispensable and
dystopian if true
of course that would be very bad news so
let's walk through the argument it's
dystopic because it's a room without
walls where everyone is always required
to be performing for everyone else and
it's a platform for human communication
in which there is no space
for careful thoughtful de-escalating
conversations it's indispensable because
it's where a lot of culture is being
created right now especially if you are
in the
like political or journalist spaces and
those people are
people who create a lot of culture it's
also indispensable because so many
important unifying powerful
conversations and ideas have started
there though those conversations are
often prevented from having a lot of
nuance because of the culture and
structure of the platform and i want to
dive into this through a very specific
and seemingly uninteresting example
these two tweets about super villains
which both did very well
pause the video to read them here's the
thing about a villain it works best if
they have
motivations that the audience can
understand there are a bunch of
different ways to do that in the carl
books the antagonist is mostly just
trying to matter which is largely the
same as one of the main motivations of
the protagonist and that's a fun dynamic
you can also have a villain that's
motivated by hurt they've been
humiliated their identity's been
destroyed now some villains just enjoy
chaos but i'd actually argue that this
is about power chaos is something
they're forcing on other people
often because they lacked agency at some
other point in their lives so now they
want to have that control and the
ultimate manifestation of that is like
world domination but among those other
ways one way
is to have the villain care about
something that is a real problem or at
least something the audience
sees as a real problem and then they
have like a super simplistic way of how
to solve that problem that is very
villainy poison ivy is right that humans
are doing significant harm to the planet
she is wrong
that killing a bunch of individual ceos
can solve a systemic problem gotham's
institutions are
definitely corrupt bane wants to solve
that problem by
blowing everything up i guess there are
a lot of things to learn from this trope
but the discourse on twitter was that
either one of two things the people
telling the stories want the people who
are watching
to be less concerned about the problems
and more concerned about policing the
tactics used to fix the problems that
was the original pitch but some of the
response was like well
actually they're trying to make people
with left-wing values into villains
so that people will think ah poison ivy
eco-terrorist people who care about the
environment are bad that second thing
doesn't make sense because villains are
often motivated by right-wing values and
nobody looks at bane and thinks ah the
batman movie is trying to teach us that
people who fight corruption are actually
bad people but the original idea that
we're focusing more on the tactics used
to fix the problems than on the problems
themselves i think that's a perfectly
legitimate
point i just think it's not the only
point in that it's oversimplified in
order to make the point and also to make
people angrier than they otherwise would
be because ultimately the goal that the
writers of the movie have
isn't to try it's not to change society
it's to sell movie tickets or whatever
it is we do now they're just trying to
figure out how to write a broadly
appealing story that'll make 300 million
dollars but if you're gonna look for
lessons i think there are others that
are also being implicitly taught here
like for example that systemic problems
are the exact problems that individuals
are very bad at solving
superman could solve a whole lot of
problems if he just declared himself the
emperor of the earth but that's not just
contrary of our ideas of what is good
and right
it's also actually evil the avengers
should not be the government that would
be dystopic they are good at punching
not leading
and thinking if i were the one
individual with all the power i would
use it to single-handedly force the
world into the shape that i believe it
should be
that's a villainous thought
we have it that but it's villainous it's
also
kind of a twitter thought of course
these stories are simple they are epic
battles that have to take place in less
than three hours and yes of course we
learn from them
and it's important to analyze what
people learn from them but if the
question is why don't the heroes in the
movies solve big problems
there are a lot of answers to that
question one answer could be disney's
trying to make leftists look like
villains
one could be disney is just generally
trying to manufacture consent but you
could take a middle road and say
disney's trying to sell movie tickets or
you could take a sympathetic view and
say the lesson to learn here is that
heroes can't solve these problems
only we can john i'll see you on tuesday